in all ha Sam II ill welcome everybody
to another episode of genius brain
podcast where we talk about anything and
everything and today we have a very very
special guest a guess who I have been
trying to get on here forever
but she refused to come on here in the
beginning and got upset when I had other
people on here instead of her because I
told her that she would be the first
person here to do this but she said that
she didn't want to so I moved on which
makes no sense yeah you moved on way too
fast
I did not move on too fast it was three
weeks hey you got to give me some time
to think about okay I'm not used to
these kind of stuff you literally did a
sketch that's because all I had to do
was hit you in corsage
which I am totally fine with but not
this one this is like a lot of talking
and I gotta be careful what I say you
know what people don't know if you guys
don't actually know this if you go back
onto my YouTube there's a sketch on
there about Kim Jong Allah that I had a
friend on with Arden Cho
so as me and Arden Cho as she was
playing my wife and Muriel was a PA on
that set and that was the first time I
ever met her and it's caught on camera
the very first day that we ever met yes
that's true and the first time I met you
you know when I first saw you you know I
thought to myself yeah like me I don't
think very anything about you I was
working yeah and I didn't really think
much of you two cuz you were wearing
socks and slippers
no slock socks and flip-flops so I was
like what the hell I still want the
fluffy socks not in front of me that
that was the first time that we met and
then we met us another time after that
and is when she decided to be a guest on
our or a Coco star in one of my fake
Korean Nike commercials I was supposed
to be your mom that was it that was it I
was supposed to be your mom and I just
have supposed to curse at you but I
didn't want to curse because I didn't
know how to curse in Korea so I can I
just punch you and you're like let's
just try it and then I went really well
and next thing I know you're like can
you be my girlfriend can you be my wife
and I was like and that's when you fell
in love and as I was like I feel so
naked that's I fell in love with me
it's amazing man dude she was she was
she was all over me dude she was she was
so we're all you saw could you couldn't
get enough of me dude you're like dude
who is this guy I have to say that you
were really funny and I was like man
he's gonna be a great friend if we keep
in touch but I never thought like more
than that okay why cuz I didn't know you
those our first time actually like first
time talking to each other cuz then the
first time we met we didn't speak to
each other
yeah but the second time I talked to you
a lot you did I remember what you were
wearing to you're wearing that white
Johnny Depp blouse the Pirates of the
Caribbean white blouse thank you oh
right your your fire pants as I call
them well it's also recorded in the
video so yeah it's easy to remember no I
just remember because I'm a good
boyfriend and I remember how cute you
were
yeah and then you looked at me and
you're like who's this hunk of fat
Korean right there I was just like oh
you're actually funny cuz at first I was
like yours you seem like a douchebag how
did you even
how did you even come to that conclusion
cuz you I mean no no no I didn't think
you're a douchebag it was just like oh
he's just anything much of you and then
the second time see I'm like wow this
guy talks a lot and he's funny
he's nice I'm like that's cool that's
cool and then I remember we were in that
room alone right before we had our
dinner and I thought I was mad flirting
with you
dude that was kind of scary I was like
why are you holding my like somehow you
held my hands and I was like no okay so
I want was i holding your hand I
remember I was I was just trying to like
test you out of a black suit if you'd
and you kind of let me know that oh she
might kind of like like me a little bit
that's when I was like no that's why I
walked away cuz he gave me that look and
I like mmm that look is kind of female
Oh which means I don't have to say it
female female is female like uh-uh not
awkward like odd he's on it mm-hmm
yeah but you still came back for some
more did I
well we're together aren't we but you
thought what a great eye you were
together you and I are in a relationship
right now yeah that's true yeah and then
I realized you're actually a nice guy
but I don't understand what made you
think I wasn't
well it was my first time seeing you you
were so confident that I felt like you
thought he could get me right away and I
was like who do you think you are
thinking that you could get me right
away let's to be honest that's how I
felt was like this guy cuz you text me
after you're like oh you know I think we
should hang out and I'm like okay he
thought you know cuz I I was thinking
like oh you think I could get me right
away it's like as if so I said when I
said so I text you back and I was like
oh boot out go ray
yeah I think you saw I was like oh you
know we'll see but for me I was like oh
toggle yeah but you still hit me back up
though well so so this is what happened
right so a few weeks after that so what
she did and she said she didn't do this
on purpose but I think she did she left
her watch at my place she left this rose
gold Cartier watch at my place and I was
like whose watch is this right and then
I just started asking around and I do
stat it was from you and I was like this
girl Cinderella slippered my ass dude
she's Cinderella's slipper my ass oh I'm
just gonna watch here and see and how'd
you just happen to leave it at my
bedside table oh because I would see it
and hit you back up you mean because
we're doing a bed scene so I have to
leave it there yeah that's what they
always left that in plain sight for me
to see I think that I was like okay so
she trying to see me again so I got her
numbers and I was like okay
TIPA TIPA tap a type of type of type a'
what's up and then she had to see me
again because I had her watch and so we
met back a second time after that or
this is the third time at our friends a
shadow spot that she was opening up in
k-town so when she opened up that spot
our our mutual friend Edie was there and
she was there too and I was like cool
I'll see you there I decided to give her
her watch then and of course lo and
behold I asked when we were gonna hang
out again right and she gave me the same
[ __ ] answer which I could which mean
we'll see so she did that crap again but
the reason why there's a there's a funny
moment too in my Instagram if you guys
look back far back into my Instagram
there's actually a picture of her and
this is a picture of her holding a plate
of random
the boats so during the opening right
she did the most Asian thing so she got
invited as a guest and then there was
leftover vegetables and she went up to
my friend and she goes or he's just
gonna throw this away can I take it home
so she literally packages up everybody's
veggies to take it home untouched
veggies untouched messy because they're
gonna go to waste it's like well I had
got no food at home might as well take
home I mean less trash for her right
yeah and I was like oh this is dope but
I have to ask you though when you cuz
you put a hashtag is's my future wife
yeah that was a joke that's kind of
ironic yeah that's it was a joke
you know and it means you know just
because I saw oh this girl's like super
frugal that like that's a down-ass [ __ ]
that's what that's what I was thinking
in my head but after that so and I asked
her to like what are we gonna hang out
and you you you agree that we were did
you like me more cuz of that I don't
know if I liked you more but I thought
you were really really attractive then
you just had like something fun about
you I didn't know what it was yet and
mind you what you don't know is that
during that time too I wasn't thinking
about settling down or trying to be in a
really serious relationship with
somebody until I was 30 mmm
so the age that I am now that's when I
was thinking okay I'm gonna like do some
serious dating until then I'll just
gonna date around mess around and just
do whatever
but until but prior to that I already
decided in my mind that hey I'm not
going to settle down with anybody mm-hmm
but then I saw you and I was like okay
well if I if I see something in this
person and I choose to ignore because I
set up this rule for myself
nobody pressed that rule upon me I
created that rule in my own mind so I
was like okay well that's dumb this is
an opportunity and you should take it so
I I decided to pursue you and it took a
very very long time it was I kid you not
from the moment that I met her to our
first date which I say is our first date
it took about two and a half months it
was like two months to two and a half
months yeah because after that shabu
thing you didn't hit me back up for like
another month you just disappeared
you were not busy you were interning at
full screen well I was hustling I was
trying to find my you know my future
career at that time did you know what
you texted me what like I didn't hit you
up you hit me up after a month yeah cuz
that's when I was like because I got
really busy with
I was working on and then when I was
coming towards to the end I was like oh
yeah I should probably hit him up and
you're like so when are we gonna go out
to eat yeah and a month passed I was
like who the [ __ ] I was like a month
passed you were you gonna give up on me
I already moved on from you at that
point really because the Lord because I
I've already tried once
no no multiple times I tried when I
first met you right you didn't but you
didn't ask me out I technically did
though I hit you up and I was like you
mean in a passive way that wasn't how
was that passive you texted me you
texted me once I'd be like hey let's
hang out that was one time I think
you're really cool we should hang out
sometime right and then there was the
watch thing then I hit you up again
that's that's twice really you hit me up
twice no it was just once though the
first time the first time was after the
sketch and I had your watch and I used
that as a segue to ask you out I was
like Yolo we should hang out let's list
let's kick it let's listen let's be
around each other and then you're like
Portugal and then I had your watch
uh-huh so that's why we saw each other
again and then after I gave you back
your watch and we had the shabu thing I
asked again and then you did that pojat
and crap again
really so so I just waited I don't want
to pressure you I already put myself out
there twice so at that point I'm
thinking yo if she wants to hit me up
the the balls in her court
mm-hmm so I've already expressed how I
felt mm-hmm and that I was interested
and then you have a month later out of
Norris I was like who the hell is this
worried but you were still interested oh
cool let's try this out and then we went
on our very first date would you say
wasn't a date was day okay how is a date
if it was a place where you didn't even
like and I picked the place and I came
with my bicycle on my gym outfit how is
that a date though like that wasn't a
date to me that was just more like let's
really just oh yeah it's it's it's a
meetup date the kind of thing and we met
up for dinner
yeah but it was like at a place are you
doing even like and we met up for dinner
and I got a freaking tick tick I got a
ticket that day coming to see you that
was a sign you should have known though
I'm not a date you're wearing this like
weird hat it was was it that goofy on it
or something but it was like eyeballs
there's eyeballs although I was like who
hell is that's exactly cuz it wasn't a
date for me it was just hey you said
let's hang out you didn't ask me out on
a date but I can't you be more
straightforward David well I wasn't sure
but it it wasn't like a very formal date
though but I was asking you out so you
have different kind of dates like
there's a formal there's like a date
where we go where we go out I buy you
dinner I probably dress up a little bit
this is like a it's like if you were on
a dating app right you meet up with that
person the first time you're probably
not going to be dressed up all the way
up I wouldn't dress up the way I did or
at that point oh yeah I guess you caught
us true self of me yeah and I made it
clear as possible that I was interested
in you so it wasn't like I was you know
what I mean well that's the thing
because I didn't know you and I know yes
like David the comedian guy who you know
has a lot of attention yeah and I don't
know how that world is and if someone's
in that world all setting gives me
interest like I don't know this guy's
just playing around being serious you
know but even if I wasn't playing around
being serious I clearly wasn't trying to
meet you up just to be your friend
right I don't know if you just wanted to
hug that that's that's your problem to
you though well it's as a girl you gotta
be careful especially in that know you
you have to be careful right but you're
not careful like that with other people
I know what you're talking about but I
am careful enough where I don't go to
that extent you know like you're not
careful every time we've had okay we'll
bring that up in in a yeah it's so
annoying but so anyways we meet up at
this place I think it was called sage
Bistro yeah in place and the first thing
I did when I said that I looked at I
goes are you vegan and she goes no like
thank God then this might work out okay
cuz the thing was that I was new to
Culver City right or the location and
you're like oh you know we should have a
dinner I'm like great you have a place
in mind and you're like do you have any
place that you like and at that time I
was really into vegan stuff like
exploring the vegan food yeah so I was
like oh let's get vegan food then if you
don't know any place like I only know
one place each and you're like he text
me by like are you vegan yeah like just
like vegan food and you're like okay
then I can meet up with you yeah
but I didn't know that you hated or
you're not a big fan of I'm it's not
that I'm not a big fan of vegan food its
I don't like vegan food that tries to be
something that it's not so for example
like vegan vegan pizza they use cashew
cheese I just don't use cheese like you
don't have to make something into
something else right unless it's like
like Buddhist Asian Vietnamese but they
do a really good job and you know why
it's because these monks for ten
thousand years we're working on this
recipe so I'm pretty sure they got it
down pat you know it's just I don't like
American vegan food a lot it just it
tastes like something that it shouldn't
taste like because they're trying to
make it taste like something else and
that's what I don't like yeah I guess so
that that's that's why I didn't like it
but we met up at the sage Bistro thing
and then we had a good time I remember
you were cracking up you are laughing I
was making you laugh and you were
laughing dude I was like this girl yeah
of course cuz you were laughing so hard
it just fell out of your memories and
that and then you rode your bike and
you're like well I'm gonna bike home and
it was super late at night it was dark
and I was like no I'll drop you off and
I just got my G I know my new Jeep and
you had a blanket for some reason
because I was moving stuff in and out
into that apartment in k-town and so I
was like oh well let's I'll drop you off
just put your bike in the car and it's
not like you just did it out of nowhere
because we already met before we have
mutual friends hmm you know so it wasn't
like too weird for me to say that we've
met twice you worked on my set twice so
we had we already had somewhat of them I
feel like a little bit iffy about it I
mean we met each other we were going
back and forth we had conversations on
the phone we met we know each other's
friends we have mutual friends so it's
kind of like it wasn't it wasn't a weird
situation for you it wasn't a random
stranger so that's why I took the offer
if not but like Helen I don't know you
yeah and so I dropped her off and this
was the funny thing too so I don't know
what it was prior to other guys that
tried to date you before but so when we
were when we were there and this is such
an interesting situation so she actually
noticed about me now but I'm a very very
very very straightforward person
I am I'm hyper straightforward like to
almost to a fault which is why I tend to
get in a lot of trouble because I don't
I've learned how to hold back a lot more
but and specifically just being in this
relationship
has taught me to be very careful about
my words instead of just saying what's
on my mind all the time which is done I
yeah
so when we were when I was saying my
goodbyes to her I gave her a I was going
for a hug which I hug everybody whether
I like somebody or not and I go for a
hug and she gives me this you know the
crappy girl hug it's there's like a
specific technique it's like when you do
a deadlift right you just kind of like
posture your shoulders up you just
spread out your chest a little bit ass
out and then she makes a super stiff and
she gives you that tap tap tap tap tap
in the back Hank yeah a little tap on
the back and I got this hug and I looked
at her and the first thing I said right
off the bat was what are you to give me
a better hug than that I was like well I
was like oh you don't give very good
hugs as I by the way we're not friends
oh okay I told her straight although
we're not friends and I remember you
were like what what do you laughing and
I was like we're not friends I'm not
trying to be your friend
we're dating that was a shock for me
because no one ever said that to me
before and none of the guys at least I
was dating or who wanted to be more than
friends they would never say that I had
I mean I don't know why so that was like
actually a shock because I didn't expect
that I didn't know like someone would
ever say that yeah well because you gave
me the hug and made me feel that you
were trying to put up a friend zone
boundary on me right like oh we could be
friends and you gave me that crappy hug
nothing
oh well let me just and I don't like the
thing where I'm not trying to do the
Korean oppa thing that I talked about
right right try to be your friend try to
be your spiritual leader and then I'm
like oh by the way oh let's date like I
don't have time for that and I think
number one is deceptive and I think that
it's it's it's very cowardly you know so
for me it's like I'd rather set my
expectations up front so you don't have
to guess what type of guy I am I want
you to know who I am upfront and if you
don't like it then you had that option
to say hey I don't feel that way about
you what's interesting is that I'm so
used to the other method and I find out
very natural I think it works in some
ways as long as you know they're both on
the same page but when you set that to
me I don't know why but that worked
super well and I didn't expect that
where I was like oh we're not gonna be
friends we're gonna
pass that and just move straight on to
dating yeah if it works you know and
it's like that stuck that phrase was
stuck in my head for the longest time
yeah and and you know what it is - it's
not like we went straight to dating
either because you and I already met
each other before we joked around we had
conversations so yeah it is kind of
sudden but I've already said a precursor
to that because we had conversations
before you know and I saw you with your
friends mm like how you interact with
them and it was really cool I mean yeah
I think if I didn't see that I think
it'll be a little bit more hesitant
because I don't know who you are
well of course like I you know that you
know when when I say these type of
things do people oh maybe I should try
that I'll say but there's there was a
lead up to it it wasn't just right off
the bat yeah it was it was studied in
kind of in context but not really
because we already met before we joked
around we message each other a lot
exactly so that's that's the difference
so when you gave me that hug I already
set up a foundation for this and then
you give me this crappy little tap tap
friend hug enough to give you a good hug
not that I yeah yeah but that thing was
like I was I held you I gonna do it to
me after everything I've done for you
this is what is I invited you to my
friends opening restaurant to eat some
shabu I'll hold up actually let's be
fair that wasn't from you and invited me
okay whatever you know she was my friend
so I'll try to get the credit for that
Edie thank you by the way either way you
would have been invited either way so
are you trying to invite me well it was
either gonna be the shaba thing or I was
gonna invite you to get your watch again
and we were gonna meet up again so and
you did compliment my fanny pack
that's right cuz I I did with I dig
fanny packs no not anymore you don't
like my fanny pack well cause he got
incredibly dirty you're even bassist
faded its dirtiest it's well used it's
been all over with me event it's been in
Taiwan Korea and here with me and hell
Hey look at your boxers okay yeah I
don't think to say I threw away those
boxers wait the one thing you didn't
want to throw away threw it away yes the
one where my ball sack went through it I
think gross I did not have to know that
I did you really I threw it away
I didn't actually want to it just
disintegrated yeah
disintegrated like a piece of tissue
paper I see
those in there they're gone okay great
did I've had that boxers since I was
this is my freshman year of college
that's so gross
you mean it was washed yeah but it's
like worn a leather it was it's it's
gone though a literally tore apart it's
done so it's gone mine hasn't been torn
apart just washed out yeah but my yeah
mine was pretty bad though anyway yeah
and then I kind of set that precursor
where I told you this is what we were
and I remember I kind of left that that
no and I moved away so in your mind you
that kind of stuck in your head though
mm-hmm and then you invited me one night
to help y'all with this script really
late and that actually freaked me out
do you remember that oh did it freak you
out I thought it was okay because you've
been to that house before and I had
roommates there no nobody was there and
it was super late on like I thought I
was gotta be there maybe for an hour or
two so it's like I'm at dinnertime you
know but we ended up like working on it
for hours I was like after midnight yeah
and like I I was so scared
oh really just cuz I thought you've
already been there and then I had
roommates too and then your roommates
weren't there oh they weren't it was
just us too so I was kind of I mean I
didn't see any like intention like bad
intention I was gonna happen
but it's still like it was late at night
I was this big empty house with just the
two of us and I was like oh I made a
mistake I shouldn't have I had no idea
well it's not like I was like hitting up
that day I was not hitting on you at all
I was exhausted because I was just
trying to get that script done yeah so I
was like in my shorts and my shirt
nothing all right well what does this
mean was it was very unemotional I was
exhausted well that's that's where I was
like oh I don't think it's gonna go
anywhere and luckily of course I wasn't
trying to anything else trying to get
work done
yeah and I realized how much work we had
yeah I was like oh my god just want to
finish this so that's that was all my
motivation Oh same here I was tired
good bye oh yeah I'm glad I'm glad I was
just it yeah man we had bad and then
after that we decided to so here's the
thing we're gonna fast-forward through
what are you gonna talk about our
relationship we are we're gonna talk
about people want to know about this to
talk about yeah okay so during this time
too we were we were in an open
relationship meaning that we weren't
really
to each other specifically we were just
trying things out and we were dating
going back and forth she was on like a
dating app or something and she was
dating some white dude it wasn't a white
dude I wasn't redhead no Russian Russian
yeah why do another white dude like it's
not white did not white American he's
Russian dude and so she she just like oh
she would do this childish thing which I
hated childish it wouldn't I love how
you still remember everything I do
remember every detail because I'm you
need to move on I did move on this is
just very interesting so she would do
this thing right well she would test me
I [ __ ] hate why do you have so much
emotion if it was just a memory because
we're telling a story dear you say it
was childish you don't think it was
childish I don't think it was a child
this I think it was just you know real
it's like I don't know who I won't say
any much cuz I want you to tell the
story but then like I didn't know how
real one was than the other yeah but you
would do things where you would pick
attributes against him against mine I
was just poking you I'll be yeah that's
just learning David Sutta that is the
worse way of learning that was not for
me do you know how you flirt yes I did
it's not attractive at all what are you
talking about the way you flirt you make
me man he make me turn off man what are
you talking about Oh we'll talk about it
so she would do this thing right where
she would be like oh well this guy well
he likes to go mountain biking he likes
to do this do you like to do that and I
was getting so irritated and I was like
first of all I'm not like I'm not a
baseball card we're not trading stats
you know and so she kept on doing this
over and over and over and mind you like
I was dating other people - at the time
- cuz we were just keeping it open and
so for her and the thing that annoyed me
the most was when she kept on doing this
thing well this guy does this this guy
does that you'd even really like the guy
either right well clearly because I
chose you yeah but that's what you were
it was so annoying it's like you even
liked him that much well what made you
want to pick me over the other many
girls you were dating well that girl was
just more like she was already in that
prata cuz my when I decided to go after
member I told you I was just dating
right so prior to you being there I was
like oh yeah
this one's very very interesting so the
other girls were kind of
we were like in a very flirtatious
friendship type of thing and then the
girl that I was dating at the time she's
the one that brought it up and said hey
why don't we just try this in my mind I
was like it's not gonna work out cuz
that's just how my gut felt about the
girl oh how come you work for it because
she asked and she was she was brave
enough to say hey like I know we're
friends but how come we don't just try
this out and I kind of I guess you could
say I respected that a lot and I was
like you know what like we are good
friends I don't feel like this will work
out but because I'm just in the dating
stage right now I might as well just
give her the benefit of the doubt and
try it out did not work out absolutely
not terrible person those aren't friends
anymore we're friends but she's not if
she's listening to this we've already
had this conversation before so I don't
feel bad saying yeah but she
number one was hyper emotional she knows
about herself and the type of stuff that
she was saying to me and getting angry
about is stuff that I experienced like
later on in in a relationship type of
thing but when we were just dating it
should be fun we should just get to know
each other so if we had a disagreement
about something she was snapping and
angry and that was a complete turnoff I
was like oh you you don't know how to
have a conversation with the human being
you just know how to get angry and when
somebody opposes a thought that you have
you think that that person is attacking
you personally right which you have it
would you used to have a little bit too
but hers was so extreme you know and I
didn't like that so it would be
something like this like let's say it's
the color red right and I'm like it
looks more maroon hmm and they should be
like no that's red I'm like are you sure
cuz like the tint might be a little off
she goes it's freakin red okay like so
that's how she would respond and I'm
like dang no that's not working out and
when I when I when I sensed that type of
like aggression I was like you got a lot
of issues and I'm not willing to deal
with it because you can't talk to me
like that and you weren't really at a
stage where like I'm gonna make this
serious either way it took a very light
exactly so like with that as we were
dating that started to fizzle out and I
was like okay well this is this girl's a
lot she's she seems way more compatible
with me and then we had a conversation I
remember because we use this app called
Kyle yeah Kakao and we were going back
and forth back and forth and she kept on
doing this thing over and over and I
finally snapped okay go go on well what
were you gonna say I wanted to mention
that one time by the way it was by
accident but it just you gotta
understand on my side the kimbap story
oh my god cuz you measured my [ __ ] oh
and I'm like oh my god the kimbap story
just popped in my head oh my god okay I
hated you so much
I had to the point where I Trent about
you and thought you were like dead
that's how much you cared that's how
much I care
yeah that's when I realized fudge I'm
like falling for this guy and I don't
know if he's like on the same boat as me
so that's why I was poking you I forgot
about that okay let's talk about the
kimbap story so prior to bliss we're
gonna go a little back prior to that so
prior to that there was well let's just
say this is the reason why I poked him a
lot and thought he thought he thought it
was childish so while we were going back
and forth joking on like Cal talk or
whatever right [ __ ] or whatever and we
were just going back and forth there was
this time I went to Sacramento and when
I was in Sacramento my mom my mom makes
amazing food and she made me kimbap if
you don't know what kimbap is it's a
seaweed wrapped like lunch in memory
incision that Korean sushi roll that
people put in there cost you duck or
there that bento their lunchboxes and so
I sent her a picture of issues like oh
it looks great it looks delicious but as
I was texting her this picture it was
when I was on my way to the airport back
to sack back to LA from Sacramento I
left my phone in my cousin's truck
mm-hmm and so I left it there and then I
couldn't find my phone I was freaking
out and then I found out my cousin he
messaged me through even the Facebook or
something else and I left my phone I
said okay it's there here's the problem
I couldn't contact her the reason why is
because all of her handles Facebook
Instagram whatever wasn't her name it
wasn't her name so I couldn't find it
through Instagram I couldn't find it
through Facebook here's the thing though
you could have found a way by talking to
your friends you could have asked Julia
and anyone Oh Julia Julia you could have
asked Edie Edie and I we had other
social media connection I could have
asked ed right but at the time Edie was
trying to hit on you
and we are allowed to say it's too late
so like it felt weird for me to try to
ask a guy that was trying to hit on you
at the same time so I was like that's a
little odd right so it doesn't matter
and so at the time I was like I can't
really ask him because it's weird right
so so I kind of was kind of stuck and
then my phone was gonna come in two days
anyways so those two days you were you
were messaging me and I didn't see it
yeah okay so that's your side of the
story right my side is like he sent me
this picture and I messaged you back and
I'm like oh it looks really good I
haven't I don't hear back from him from
a whole day right and I'm on my
Instagram funny thing is his Instagram
is constantly getting updated and I'm
like and then apparently it was like a
really sad Instagram so I'm passing away
and so I got really worried and it's all
I kept messaging him I'm like hey is
everything all right that it uh and I
get no response from him I have a
horrible dream that something happened
to him and I'm like could have fall
asleep and I wake up the next in and
instead of being worried I got mad so
mad I was like this guy is totally
playing with me I'm so done with this
and then as soon as I was thinking about
that he messaged me he's like hey I'm
sorry I left my phone I like my cousin's
car dadada and I was like then how the
hell did you update your Instagram I
have iPad and he's like I have my iPad I
was like I had my iPad Oh mad at you and
I have so much thinking like so many
thoughts were going through my head I
was talking to my friend my friend was
like you seemed so frazzled and like all
over the place I'm like hi and I'm like
this guy's driving me nuts and then my
friend was like who is this guy I'm like
I can't tell you yeah cuz I don't know
what's gonna happen and then you texted
text me back and after that I was like
you know what I got to figure this out
that's when I started poking you know
what was so funny too because when I saw
that message and you texted me something
else after I was like she's gonna be
pissed
I read you right at the bat so the first
message that I sent she was super long
cuz I had to explain everything I was at
I left my car I left my phone in my
cousin's car you don't have your
Facebook I can't find you through your
Facebook you had all your facebook
Instagram all your social handles
is on my name though it wasn't it was no
it was it yes it was Muriel
Yeah right yeah what did you tell me
your name was Muriel no it wasn't what
the Freak ed knows me as Muriel I might
have put in Mary but I couldn't find you
on facebook or cuz we didn't have any
connected friends or something but I
couldn't find you on facebook I couldn't
find out what you're such a liar if I
liked you and I was pursuing you that
much don't you think I would have done
everything to hit you up you dad that's
different though that's a very awkward
situation and you can say out loud now
yeah oh my gosh okay whatever
and so you I didn't find you and my
phone was coming in a couple days too
and so I just explained myself through
that that I couldn't message you because
of these reasons and I remembered you
mentioned the Instagram thing I was like
because of my iPad I had that and you we
don't have any other friends connect it
besides that one person everybody else
was it do you see I'm saying so I
couldn't find you so but when I finally
got my phone back I did message you you
wouldn't have dude oh you have that much
touch touch and go
hell yeah I did you wouldn't have Wow is
that why you didn't search enough okay I
fell for it after this we had a
conversation where we're gonna go back
were she kept on doing this thing where
she kept poking me and I got I have a
good reason right I don't know if that's
a good reason I see
dude you should have been on my shoes oh
my gosh I was dying for two nights
yeah but I explained myself yeah but two
nights I couldn't sleep it was like it
was a disaster and I was like you know
what and he had that much confidence in
me so I was like you know why this guy
better not be playing with me that's why
I started poking you yeah and so this
kind of goes into the to what I said to
her after and this this this goes to
that attribute of me being really
straightforward and I I said this to her
I'm during the texting she was doing
that crap again and I got really upset
and I kind of snapped and I was like hey
listen I remember what I said too
because it was so precise because when I
sent it I was very confident about it
but after I sent it I regretted it I was
like oh god she's gonna hate me like I
sent it with such confidence but
afterwards I was like you regret it
she's gonna leave me you know what's
weird though I didn't see that was like
being like aggressive her man I thought
it was just like a sincere
it was very sincere but it was like I
wanted to cut through the [ __ ] right
so you know what's so funny though what
I wanted that that's what I was about or
is so damn annoying that's so that's so
annoying
surely cuz I wanted to know what you
wanted for me you I already told you
though relax
that's the thing no I'm not gonna relax
I already told you like I don't know how
like it was so obnoxious because I was
so straightforward with how I felt how I
behaved around you like it was already
there like the house tree fort I was
after that was ridiculously
straightforward you know it was extreme
so what I wrote to her was this I was
hey like I I don't know if you have
something confused or not but right now
you have something twisted I said I'm
not trying to figure out if I'm good for
you I'm trying to figure out if you're
good for me I actually don't know you
and I don't owe you anything so I've
told you how I felt this is how I feel
and if you have to figure out what you
want to do on your end
so I told you this is how I am so you
need to figure it out and then you let
me know and I just ended the
conversation and then after that I just
kind of ended it I went to sleep and I
thought you're so mean otherwise it was
like 3 o'clock in the morning yeah and
you were having a drink with Paul right
Paul
Paul is it was it with Paul pills it was
like you were having a drink with Paul
that's why I was a little drunk that's
right yeah I was like a almost like a
tipsy text I was like you wrote really
well yeah
and so I told her that's right I forgot
about that yeah Oh drinking with Paul
that night at my place that's I think
that's why I like I took it more sincere
because you were drunk and you still had
you know I was tipsy harness and then
you know I just wrote it straight for it
I was like you need to figure out what
you want cuz I already told you how I
felt and and you know when I go back in
time I look at I was like that is true
though like I told you how I felt this
is what I am so I'm tired of you picking
me against somebody else who I really
don't care about you just need to figure
out on your end I'm honest so that's
when I
ended with that guy cuz he want you that
was like the time where he wanted to
move forward to it and I was hesitant
because I felt like my heart was towards
I wasn't there would you move forward
with him
maybe if he was the only one possibly
really not I don't know I don't think so
I didn't seem like you liked them I
think I saw him more as a friend yeah
cuz when he did make that move I was
like I'm kind of tired I'm gonna go home
and then all I could think of us
messaging you mmm oh my god how'd you
see like me anyway oh my god tux fat so
after you messaged me that I yeah I was
like you know what I'm gonna tell this
guy and he took it really cool like he
was like you know hope for the best for
you to love I hope he make you very
happy he definitely didn't have that
from Russia
he's just Russian American I hope he
make you very happy in Mother Russia you
would be wife already
I mean you don't like you don't think it
sound very sexy little Asian woman would
you like to be my wife I like the
Filipino accent please take my hand I
never bought to get the bottle of that
I'm going to give you like it so much
but yeah anyway so after that I cut it
off and then what was it like lead that
night the next day or something like I
kept messaging over like hey we need a
meet-up yeah and then you're like can we
meet up now I'm like no it's too late we
got to meet up in the next morning yeah
and I was like no let's meet up now cuz
it was gonna bother me all night it was
gonna it was bothering me that I had to
tell you but like it was so late on I
don't want to like it was late I was
like 12 o'clock yeah yeah super late so
we met up in the morning at a restaurant
Marchmont
it was in Larchmont it was watched my
bungalow mm-hmm and that's when we had
the talk and decide to get together you
see how annoying it was for me to get
with you but that was like a four-month
ordeal
it was so obnoxious and was that where
they were still together so don't you
don't you ever question my love if four
months about for us to finally get
together
and it's not like I played any games
that was the anointing I didn't play
games that's true so I was like okay
what is she trying to figure out even
say yes or no mm yeah I mean cuz it was
you I mean to be honest your career is
not normal like a average career of
course you know there's a lot of things
that will be part of my life that I
wasn't aware of or I don't even know
what it's gonna be like mm-hmm
you know because when we go on dates
like you get so much attention from
people and I'm just like not aware of it
and don't know how to react to it and
like is this gonna be like up for
everything you know there's just a lot
of obligations that I didn't know how I
should react or if I should consider
about it yeah then later on like when I
got to know you I was like you know what
those are just like that's just his
career that's nothing more than that you
know cuz like I wasn't sure if you were
gonna be a different person if when
you're around your fans or like you know
when you have the spotlight but you were
just you yeah I just had to see those
kind of moments and make myself feel
comfortable mm-hmm and so once I saw
that and I was like you know he seems
like a good guy genuine guy no two-faced
I felt that you thought that I slept
around one with a lot of women like I
like I was just a dude that just slept
with everybody which I'm not I didn't
know that I understand but like I guess
okay and because you're such an
easygoing guy and he who's really like
funny
and you could talk to anyone that you
know there's I thought you could do that
with anyone as well yeah why I speak
very well so even so Julia was producing
that sketch and even she knew that I was
really attracted to you Julia is
probably the only person ever that
actually saw me a flirt with somebody
like in that type of context because
people see me be friendly with everybody
where there's a guy or girl right and so
they would they would see this
friendliness and like oh is he's
flirting with this girl I'm like that's
not flirting there's a difference and
Julie's the only one that saw the
difference cuz even Julia was like oh
he's really friendly but you know he
like is he trying to be flirtatious or
not and then she saw the difference she
goes oh that's friendly David that
flirty David is way different yeah I
remember she was like I knew it yeah
once we got together Julia I was like
knew it I knew it from the get-go yeah
so when people see me around like my
homegirls right sometimes people don't
know who we are they're like oh they
have a flirtatious relationship I'm like
that's not floatacious like that's not
me being flirty at all whatsoever cuz
how I interact with them is how we also
interact with the dudes you know because
I'm not I'm not scared of my sexual Don
I didn't know how you interact with
other friends yeah cuz that was my first
time really engaging with you I mean I
saw you work with Arden but that was at
the same time like because we're working
so like I didn't know any harder and I
joke around a lot right but I don't
flirt with her like that's not flirting
so yeah at that time - you're even any
other time was never attracted to her so
it's like you know that's it's very
platonic you know what I mean I mean
just because I I make somebody laugh or
we have a good time it doesn't mean that
I'm attracted to them and I think up for
a lot of people - they don't see I guess
like having platonic opposite sex
relationships it's it's kind of hard to
see just because arguably so I do
understand because a lot of guys have an
ulterior motive when they hang out with
the girl one-on-one exactly which in
happens a lot yeah like I say for me
what I've seen from my experience I've
seen it happen like I say 80% of the
time it's because a guy wanted something
else it's like 90% yeah with me so you
know that's why I had to be very
cautious but yeah you didn't have to
because I told you what I wanted yeah
but everybody says like oh I'm just
being a nice old bar and yeah I was
trying to be a doll God like with that
lady what you're doing and I remember
alright because that's how I like it
oh my gosh where you go no mama
something self what what though oh yeah
given that missing as a piece of crap
dude I thought for the headphone yeah I
bought this for no reason
yeah but I was very straightforward hmm
you just played so much games you know I
thought a lot of guys were
straightforward too and then I learned
my lessons anyway but the the conclusion
is that we've been together for over
four years and and what would have
happened if I ran away from all that
stuff that all those obstacles you put
in front of me you know what you are
this is what it is it's like you're that
person where we're driving on the
freeway and I'm that nice American
that's all your gas tank open mm-hmm and
I'm catching up to you to tell your gas
tanks open but you're like oh this
person is trying to try to start a fight
you're right
highway and I'm just trying to tell you
hey lady your gas tanks open you know
why it's because the way you interact
and you say things and the way you look
look like you would do that you're
judging a book by it's cover I sure AM
you know what sometimes you just have to
because after being convinced so many
times we thought it was good but it
wasn't he just happy to end up judging
by its cover sometimes you just gotta be
like you guys just have that extra step
extra I think it's okay for you to be
cautious but there are times where when
we were going out - there was somebody
that was around her right that was
trying to do I guess the quote-unquote
opah thing right it wasn't it was it was
okay so basically she was getting a new
job somewhere and this person right who
she just met was telling her like oh I
can help you out with this I can help
you out with that she just met this dude
and I looked at her I was like you know
this guy's hitting on you right
like there's no there's no ulterior
motive for somebody that you just met -
bend over backwards to help you out in a
career that he gains nothing from and
you're a very cute pretty girl and this
guy's always asking you out to go have
dinner and stuff and drinks and I'm like
you do know that he's hitting on you
right and then I remember you got upset
at me cuz you're like oh are you she's
you brought up your parents which really
pissed me off
I remember this conversation very well
cuz you were talking about how your
parents don't trust you and they you
know they don't even give you a chance
and stuff and I was like I'm not saying
that what I'm saying is like I know guys
and he's clearly hitting on you he's
asking you out to dinner he's paying for
dinner he's doing this he's going the
extra step and then what happened and
then afterwards you had that dinner and
I was like all right cool we'll just see
what would see what's gonna happen and
then he started making like sexual jokes
and advances you at the dinner and then
you came back and you called me and
you're like hey so this is what happened
and I was like what and I felt so
vindicated because you made me you made
at that time you made me feel like I was
that overly jealous boyfriend and for me
it was the signs were clear as day right
it wasn't even like the dude was trying
to hide it it was just like oh he's
asking you out on a date and you're like
no well I didn't think it was again I
didn't think it was a date cuz it was
some janky place where we just found all
around the
corner and I was like okay let's just
have dinner here whatever let's see
that's what I'm saying
and then well the thing is he's like
it's hard because he was kind of dere
for me to get my job not not that he did
anything but he was just kind of there
for me and then you know as appreciation
like I was like oh yeah let's have
dinner so it was really nothing and then
when we really started to talk like he
just kind of went to a different topic
where I was very uncomfortable and so
after that I didn't hang out with him it
I don't yeah but I'm saying like a good
sign for four young ladies out there if
there's a guy that you met that bends
over backwards to help you out in
something it has nothing to do with him
ask you out to dinner there's definitely
an ulterior motive right not to that
person's fault it's just that's what it
is you just can't go in there naive
thinking like oh this guy is just gonna
set me up for the future for no reason
nah I wasn't thinking though like I
wasn't you know like go Masood oh yeah
do you know what that is
c'mon Souter like um I said yeah even
though you're like yeah now it's gonna
be welcome it um like isn't it's not
like I was like sucking up to him
yeah you know it was just you don't have
to because he wants something from you
that's so weird cuz he I mean it was
married doesn't matter if it dudes
married Amun doesn't mean this is this
is actly why because I got I still fall
into those like traps so that's why I'm
like extra cautious when it comes to
like someone saying I want to date with
you yeah you know cuz it creeps a creep
doesn't matter if they're married or not
they're still a creep right so that's
like for us to like she knows the rule
it's like for me I'm you have to admit
I'm very whatever whoever you hang out
with this fine right if she's very
specific situations like you hang out
with the guy one-on-one cool I just
gotta know who he is hmm you don't have
to ask me permission I just gotta know
who that guy's faces and he has to meet
me hmm
I just want to meet him so he knows the
face who I am you know it's like oh cool
nice to meet you my name is David blah
blah it's not like I'm telling you'll
have her back at a certain time it's not
that it's just for me it's more like
I'm not worried about what you'll do I
just know how guys are
that sounds like a dad thing I guess so
it's about people I care about
right so for me it's just like cool he
just has to know my face so if he knows
my face something will pop up in his
head and be like okay maybe I shouldn't
right whether he might I mean you don't
know like it like I said there's you
already know this - there's a bunch of
dudes that act like they're your friends
and they for I mean for what reason
would a guy that you just met want to
always hang out with you one-on-one all
the time it wouldn't make sense Yeah
right so mind you all your friends that
you met prior to me that if they're guys
I don't ever question it they've been
around before me hmm I don't know I
don't know your relationship I just know
that they've been around and you guys
have been friends so I'm okay with it if
it's a new person in your life that I
think you just met I would like to meet
this dude cuz I don't know him I don't
trust them hmm what if you have 101 I
mean whether it's work-related or not
you have one-on-one with the lady but I
never met that person I think if it's
work-related you should be okay cuz it's
just cuz I thought that was work-related
what was work-related the guy who had
dinner with but it wasn't though well I
only find out after the fact yeah but he
wasn't you guys weren't doing work we
were talking about work not really
though that wasn't well that was my
intention
you sound like I wanted to be friends or
like talk about something else that it
was what I could do that at like lunch
getting coffee yeah or something
what well I mean I wasn't thinking about
oh let's plan to have lunch and talk
about work it was just like we are
having a conversation it was late after
work and it's like oh let's go eat I'm
like yeah you know cuz we were talking
about but they were like clear other
signs too that I that I that was like so
glaring well I'm just saying that like
what if you had the situations where you
had one-on-one with a girl who I've
never met
like if it's work-related I don't think
you should be worried cuz you see me
work I'm very work work like even even
the the first time that we met right
when it was work-related it was just
work I mean what but it's not about you
personally and on top of that too like I
think like with dinner and and stuff
like that most likely I would meet them
up for lunch
daytime coffee I'm not trying to meet
them at night
you know unless I've had a relationship
with them before right so you would
never have like even early dinner with a
girl most likely not if it does that
does happen maybe it's been a while
though like I can't even remember the
time that I met somebody new a girl
mm-hmm that I've had dinner with
one-on-one that you didn't know I know I
mean I don't know a lot of your
girlfriend's already to begin with you
do you know most of them but then you
also had a relationship prior to seeing
me yeah well if it's girls that's been
around before you you should know that
if we've been friends for like five plus
years and nothing's happened it's not
gonna happen now you know what I mean
that's like the same thing for you like
a guy that's been around for whatever
ten plus years or five plus years and
then nothing's happened pretty so let's
just say you meet a new friend who's a
girl right you just met a new friend and
let's just say you have this opportunity
to have a dinner yeah whatever or like
hanging out one-on-one date time
whatever like are you are you planning
to introduce her to me first or just how
does that work
I don't know I guess I haven't really
thought about that because it doesn't
ever happen cuz yeah I mean it it
doesn't happen but what if it doesn't
because you want me to introduce my guy
friends to you first before we hang out
and one-on-one if it does happen right
usually I don't hang out one-on-one well
that's one thing it's it doesn't really
happen a lot but that's right so like do
you expect yourself to introduce that
well like for example you go somewhere
right and the only reason why I bring
that up is because like for example you
went on a trip with the co-worker right
and you met up your friends up over
there and you guys are snowboarding
buddies right let's say something
happens to you I don't have a contact
mm-hmm like I don't have a contact so so
it's like else okay that's like extreme
cuz that's like me going somewhere but
then just like hang out yeah I mean
that's your choice you just have to tell
me it's like okay well I'm gonna have to
know what this dude it's like cool who
is he
you know I want to know who he is hmm
but then if you never met it let's just
say we have a lunch or something or
lunch lunch coffee whatever that's cool
but dinner is different
dinner is different depending on who
brought it up like it just it's like a
gut feeling for me right so most likely
cuz if a guy didn't so where where did
dinner become like because it's a love
because there's a lot more intimate
right and it's just from my experience
and if you've experienced it too with me
we're guy usually I'll ask you out to
dinner is such an intimate long thing
there's something that's expected after
there says daytime that's not like that
right so like the typical thing is a guy
in a girl go out to dinner to have a few
trees and they hook up complicated yeah
so that's like the the I guess like
traditionally what happens and it does
happen yeah so so my thing is like okay
if you guys if this guy who just met she
wants to get to know you why does have
to be over dinner where the person buys
the dinner for you and everything else
that doesn't make sense to me like would
you do that for somebody you don't care
about you know what I mean mmm-hmm and
make sense more often times than not
that's what happens in my experience too
and also in your experience so that's
why if it was a case where it wasn't
like that most of the time then I'd be
way more comfortable but like you even
said I said 80% you said 90% of the time
so you know what I mean you had that
personal experiences so so I've i and
we've talked about it so that's why I'm
more weary of it usually if I'm like
comfortable with that friend then you
know having dinner would it be yeah you
know I you're right yeah yeah cuz even
when you were comfortable with therefore
your friend they still did it like
friends that you were comfortable with
they still been it right see if that's
what I'm saying so it's happened so many
times to you because you're a very sweet
girl and they take your kindness as
affection good think you're so that's
why I like if you were a type of girl
that I knew that you were just
straight-up straightforward like I am
right like girls are also sort of girls
that are very good at like not like you
ain't there's nothing well I say that
after we're after the fact
Oh girls is like I mean granted like I
was single back then when they did ask
me so there was no wrongdoing I guess
it's just maybe I gave the wrong message
but you know afterwards I'd be like you
know you're my friend and then I would
never see them yeah but it would have to
get to that point I'm saying I know
there are there are certain girls that
are very good at being straightforward
with how they feel right that guys can
sense it right off the bat like boom
we're just friends you don't have that
really you're very friendly like it's
very do you don't know what it is really
yeah cuz you're too close you think
everybody's a nice person no
that's how you behave though Mary you
don't have that thing where it's set out
in front like hey you're not gonna get
something from me it's not like that
that's why that's why that happens to
you so often
none bees know still these days - right
yeah like if I wasn't around if they
didn't see my face everywhere online you
know what I mean and it was very well
known and I'm a big angry Korean dude
you know it would be a it would probably
be a very different situation for you
I'm not but you know like it's a it
would be a very different I guess yeah
it's in a way it's kind of I do feel a
little bit protected that people do know
they know who I am right because if not
I'm pretty sure they would have stepped
on you a little step to you a lot
earlier hmm what can I say you know it's
because you don't have that thing where
you're like hey boom this is what it is
you just don't have it yeah they said oh
it's not like a bad thing you know it's
just that for you you're just being
yourself and people take that kindness
as something else you know and some of
these dudes they just like okay well why
not I'll try like even the guy that was
married he was married he didn't care he
just saw this girl that wanted to go go
have drinks and dinner with him and he
was oh maybe I could try this out so he
tested his waters and that's what people
do they test their waters they go well
let's see how far I can get away with
this and that's why you see like in
co-worker situations where ladies do and
guys do cheat on their spouse because
there's somebody who even though they
know that they're married
they'll test that water and they'll see
what will happen maybe something's wrong
in their relationship maybe I could be
that person that's gonna step in I'm not
saying it happens all the time yeah but
people do do that it does happen well
please don't take advantage of my
kindness people yeah it happens though
yeah you're right I'm too kind
time to time yeah it's it's not a bad
quality though it's a really good
quality that you have it's just I think
sometimes like because you are such a
kind person people don't see you as
being somebody who's very street savvy
and you know you don't really you don't
I mean should we live in a world where
you have to be like that you know I just
want to be me and I don't want to change
myself just for the others yeah I don't
think you should either you know I think
one of the things that maybe you could
try is just Ashley I don't know I think
you're doing perfectly fine
perfectly fine I don't think you should
have to change yourself for how other
people behave I think that Donna Donna
yeah so I'm thinking just for you just
have a little more Street savviness - no
- put it out like hey boom this is what
it is and you'll see - once you put it
out they stop being fast friendly to you
as nice to you they stop doing stuff for
you you know what I mean then it's like
oh so now you could really see the
motive because what happened to this
kind of before is because they're not
getting what they want out of you
I've definitely had those moments
already so exactly just sex and it's
such a dbag thing to do it's like oh I
oh yeah of court and they say what do
they say they go oh oh I knew we were
just friends could it then what then
what happened to all the yeah what
happened to all the nice stuff like you
just stopped being nice right yeah
suddenly you're opening the door for
yourself you're doing those are the
things cuz you're like oh maybe that's
just a nice guy thing it's like no
because they wanted something out of me
and they didn't get it and they know
they're not gonna get it so they stopped
doing that stuff I just saw some guys
are not all guys but those were the
situations that you would get in that's
why for me I'm a little more wary with
you just because I know how nice you are
so now I'm like okay like it's just
gonna try to take advantage of my
girlfriend and that's what I think now
because it happened a couple times now
it's like okay now I gotta see this
guy's face away that's how you feel yeah
so I I want to see the dude's face I
want to talk to the guy so at least they
know who I am they know my voice and
they know that means you should come to
more of my like events that I go to not
that I have a lot of events but I don't
want but you know they should know and
so like for me it's like okay maybe I am
being a little overprotective
but because it's happened a lot and I
know that you're just a very sweet
person that I don't want you gotta know
though I do take care of myself very
well you do I don't think you I just it
just I don't want it to get to that
point I don't I don't think I could I
mean for someone who have been in
different countries and different you
know living in different countries
meeting a lot of different guys like I
don't think I ever put myself in that
situation where I was dangerous or you
just got really lucky a lot you've had
some pretty terrible stories though I
did have terrible stories but God loves
me protecting me thank the Lord but I
think I've done I've been at least
somewhat smart enough not to get myself
into some of those stories that you told
me gave me anxiety though I'm
how did you come out fine well that's
what I'm saying that's why I get worried
so well I mean and also I was really
young I was reckless and young yeah like
I'm a lot better and I don't put myself
in that kind of situations no you know
so don't you worry honey I know I just
feel like as we gotten together long or
to like I think like when you care about
somebody more you do think about them a
lot you know so if I if I see certain
habits that you have I mean for you to
and me like you know I have certain
habits every time I leave you like you
like wallet phone keys how many times
have I lost those things right or I
finally like don't hurt yourself don't
overdo it
yeah why do you hate hearing those I
hate here but you're right though cuz I
always lose my wallet for me and I
always hurt myself yeah so like those
things were just stuck in our head
because we have seen a pattern of us
kind of like being in those bad
situations and you do that for me and so
I'm just trying to do it for you because
it's not me saying like oh you shouldn't
hang out with this person it's like no I
just want to see that person so I could
do my due diligence as a boyfriend and I
could know the least I could do is do
that right be like hey this is why I
don't this is where I realized that
emotions are so sensitive with
relationship like comparative friendship
because like you would never I mean you
see all those habits with your long-term
friends yeah but then you never think
about like getting super worried about
that and like you know kind of nagging
to them of like don't forget this
remember not to do that
yeah but you do that with your
relationship and then it does become
like oh you sound like my parents are
like you get agitated because you
already know what your habits are you
don't need to hear it again but then you
can't help but to worry about that
person you say any no that they don't
need to hear it per se but then you
still have to say it because I feel like
it's a checklist for us because it goes
at least I did my due diligence to tell
that person so now it's your
responsibility about whether it happens
to you or not but then that comes to I
told you so I hate that I've never said
I told you so though like I said I've
always felt it but I've never said I say
that a lot a time like I don't like
saying that I feel like a little in my
mind I'm like but I never say it out
loud because I know it would piss you
off
good then you say that to me deepest no
because you're right but then you and I
are different
like how you take information or I told
you so's is way different than I'll say
it I'll take it because when you say I
told you so I just get more embarrassed
just like yeah at least you don't get
triggered I don't get mad I just get
embarrassed because it would you were
right yeah I'm a little kind of like
jump girl really she's right uh I hope
you can say L out and admit it I mean
like you're right now I'm not gonna
admit it but you should you never say
that I should you know though cuz I say
all I'm like you're right oh right yeah
I do though sometimes rarely that's cuz
usually I'm right that's why
cuz I'm really wrong dubbing voice
friend yeah
the Builder the those are like the
differences between me and you yeah
right yeah so all of those and we're
still hanging yeah I mean you're
different but you're not that different
I think you're different like the
biggest I think the biggest hurdle that
I had to go through with you was how how
you were raised compared to how I was
raised like you rural turd I didn't grow
a sheltered I was thrown into like the
fire yeah you know so I guess I was in a
bubble yeah you were like that chino
hills' diamond bar bubble I was like I
was like the girl from Mean Girls living
in Africa like just in my own world
and I also don't have to engage with all
these people I've never engaged yeah
like different colors different people
using different languages it was just
like and you lived among those people
yeah and I wasn't I didn't know how to
work with school like like like how it's
weird because people see like cultural
diversity in two different ways right
they go oh I grew up in a very diverse
area and what they say by diverse they
just mean that I grew up with other
people who weren't white and that
doesn't mean diverse mm-hmm
like you see my group of friends back in
Sacramento right you've seen I hang out
with a bunch of like Middle Eastern
people Vietnamese Chinese white black
Mexican it's all mixed yeah you know
like we all interact with each other we
understand each other's culture were
hyper respectful of each other
just because that's what we grew up in
you know that's what I loved about
Sacramento a lot and I realize with you
you actually didn't grow up like that so
when I was show you the weddings that I
would take you to my friends like whoa
what is this
it was fascinating because you grew up
in a hyper Chinese area Chinese and
Korean Basque in my my Korean
interaction was when I went to Korean
church but then at school it was
Vietnamese black Mexican white I mean we
have those we had diversity to but then
we hung out with our own culture yeah so
like yeah we have black Vietnamese
Indians in our school but I've never
seen them because we only hung out with
our microbe was full of Chinese yeah you
just hang out with our only our clique
so that's all I need like I knew Jay
Chou from you know like I know when his
concerts were I know what f4 was which
is this Chinese what is it boys over
flower'
have a boyband like I know all these
Chinese so it was a long way home yeah
but like I didn't know anything else
outside of that and I knew my Korean
stuff because obviously because I'm
Korean yeah by the way I'm 7.5 Japanese
0.5% Japanese I'm so proud of that right
now cuz my dad I just I told myself like
my dad looks very Japanese and let's be
Japanese oh ok I understand his bulgy
eyes anyway yeah so when you told me
what like well after I met you I really
understood what diversity meant yeah la
is not diverse at all yeah la's
diversity is very different it's like
there is a lot of cultures and languages
here but it seems very spread out
there's Thai town there's little Armenia
there's Little Saigon there's there's
like I don't know whatever all those
different ethnicities are separate and
they kind of kick it with themselves but
in a certain radius yeah Sacramento is
more mixed right so we do have that in
Sacramento to like LA does but you'll
see a lot of people mix their cultures
together right that's why I like a lot
of sac people they're just so chill yeah
I mean we're just that we're a smaller
town too and there isn't like that
celebrity dream here so people aren't
pretending to be something that they're
not you know I feel like a lot of the
times when people say especially about
LA people they go oh these LA people are
like this I don't think it's the people
who are who grew up in live in LA it's
everybody else who comes into this city
that makes it that way because they
believe that they have to act a certain
way to be LA life yes all my close
friends here are from LA cuz we don't
like that they're very
down-to-earth and chill because that's
their hometown they don't have to be
anything that they're not this is just
who they are so that that perception
that people have of LA is very skewed
yeah you know and I not to mention like
because I lived in different places when
I was younger yeah like I was always you
know I don't know if you felt this way
but then wherever I moved to I always
felt like I was the outsider like even
though I was Korean or I am Korean like
when I moved to Korea when I was younger
I felt like an outsider because I didn't
know how to speak their language mhm and
then I did go to international school so
there are some what Americans there but
then the Americans were outsiders and I
hated that and it was like my grades
were so evil those girls and so I hate
you know Korean girls yeah Korean girls
man regardless of their age man they
could get evil but Bob said I hated it
so my parents and I we finally decided
to come back here and you know because I
got so used to Korean culture like when
I came back here I didn't know how to
speak the language here know just like
felt like another outsider and then not
to mention I went to a private school
and I went to a Christian school and
there were no Asians there it was all
black white Mexican yeah and I felt even
more outsider because I not only did I
not know the language but I know the
culture and I didn't know the people
yeah and so you know I was always in my
bubble like I was like I just have my
little dolls like I could talk to I felt
like having a Haupt like I was Robin and
it wasn't until Diamond Bar where I
finally settled and you know I got to
find my people it's hard to kind of
settle or figure out a cooper friend
when you're always bouncing around back
and forth yeah I didn't know who I was
and a lot of times when you're super
young like your identity is based on the
people you're around you're so
influential but you know you're you're
absorbing so many different cultures so
many different languages just kind of
don't know where to fit in yeah and who
knows how long you're gonna stay there
because you might move again so you
can't even get attached to these people
yeah it's rough I play with my dolls
that's how you talk to yourself all the
time like a crazy person I do I do talk
to myself a lot which is quite
entertaining that was the weirdest thing
about it like I would see her she's just
talking and in like three different
languages and I'm like are you are you
talking to me
no I'm just talking to myself I'm like
oh my god I'm just having conversation
to myself with different languages I
could keep it up but look at me now I
can't speak Chinese okay you know as
guys you were before but you were still
speaking just very little
not a little thank you that was like
dude we'll have interior Chinese it's so
bad
but even Bart says your Chinese is
better than his dumb I'm sure his is
better than now like I don't have anyone
to practice with Chinese is something
you can't practice on their own I
realize it's like Japanese Korean I
could told him what do you see Becky you
should just practice with it I do time
your time but she's like girl your
Chinese was better than mine like what
happened I'm like oh well an hour and
six minutes in or so we did it or ours
though see that wasn't too bad right
that first one good we actually recorded
the first one it was so bad she just
wouldn't you wouldn't speak why we talk
like this all the time dokey don't you
sitter cuz you don't like my
hyper-emotional outside of me I do like
your hyper emotional side especially on
cameras perfect just do what a camera
more than a camera yeah
Oh anyways guys I hope you enjoyed this
very special guest man it was very hard
to get her on here but you guys heard
the whole origin story of how Meryl and
I got together there's a lot more to
this story too but that was just like
the concise like clean packaged version
but uh yeah you guys can check us out on
iTunes we're talking about Spotify cast
box basically any audio platform you
could see is there I'm not gonna say all
the names but I'm just saying the
typical ones iTunes Spotify and cashbox
what's Kasbah cashbox is like the the
audio platform that you use when you're
on android for podcasters like audiobook
was that for books only investing and
yeah man uh we will see you guys next
time remember if you're watching on
youtube comments below write about stuff
that you want us to talk about guess you
want me to bring on perspectives that
you guys want us to I guess elaborate
and speak on or something I can't even
speak English anyways guys check us out
on iTunes as well give us that five star
because we're gonna need it we're trying
to get up there and smash this podcast
base because we're offering something a
little different it's normal people with
great perspectives and great ideas we'll
see you guys next time peace